Harry Potter in the order of the Phoenix
we are chugging along in the Harry
Potter universe I'm having so much fun
talking about these movies with you guys
this was the first one to be directed by
David Yates who continued to direct
every single film after that as well as
the upcoming fantastic beasts it's very
clear as this film opens and it's going
to be a different vision than we had
previously experienced there's something
about the way this film opens that felt
almost dreamlike even though we were
watching events that were happening a
lot of the order of the Phoenix is about
dreams and visions and prophecies but
this opening actually captured that
feeling somehow this was also the first
time we got to see Dudley and his little
gang of bullies which had been
previously mentioned in the other films
after they pick on Harry for a while
what else is new the Dementors come and
harry has to defend Dudley against this
Dementor who is killing him which means
he used a spell outside of school and he
gets a letter saying that he's expelled
from Hogwarts for this and this is just
our first hint at what umbrage will do
look I thought the Dursleys were bad
I thought Draco Malfoy was bad no one's
as bad as Umbridge this is the worst
person ever in this movie Dolores
Umbridge takes over Hogwarts she makes
all these absurd rules she stops
teaching the kids about magic she tries
to use the Ministry of magic to make
everything at Hogwarts change because
Harry Potter is the only person trying
to tell everyone that Voldemort is back
and no one wants to believe him all of
this pressure that's being mounted on
Harry in this movie continues to
solidify his status as the everyman
character or in this case the everyboy
character that guy that you just relate
to that person you're like oh my god I
know exactly how you feel man he's a
very sympathetic character that you care
about but he's also not that guy just
sits there like I hate life oh look some
Harry Potter
Voldemort wants to kill me everyone
hates me
he's angry about it and rightfully so
but he's also reserved about it he's
being mature about it and that's why
Harry continues to be such a fantastic
role model as a character and a great
character that we can actually get
behind and root for
so when Harry is facing expulsion from
Hogwarts Alastor Moody returns to rescue
him and takes him to meet the order of
the Phoenix a secret group of people who
are trying to do some good and Sirius
Black played by Gary Oldman is involved
with this as well and there's a great
reunion there but there's one specific
aspect about this movie that I really
latched on to Harry's character in this
one specific scene where he witnesses a
building split in half and he still has
that look of awe this isn't boring to
him he's still so excited about magic so
since he used magic out of school Harry
is put on trial and Dumbledore defends
him excellently but this is our first
encounter with Umbridge who i've already
mentioned as a complete bitch but
thankfully Harry is cleared of these
stupid charges and we get to go to
Hogwarts with him but as I said pressure
is mounted so much on Harry in this
movie because kids in school are reading
headlines about him people think perhaps
Harry's crazy because he's saying all
these things about Voldemort being back
Cedric Diggory the Murray is not being
honored properly because people are
making up lies about how he died and
Harry tries to be the one who stands up
and says no Voldemort's back he killed
Cedric we have to honor his memory you
guys are doing a disservice to this kids
memory and once the kids start to
believe Harry Harry Ron and Hermione
form a secret society of kids in which
they find the Room of Requirement and
start training each other on how to
defend themselves against an oncoming
war that Harry is positive is coming and
this is so great because we get to see
Harry step into the role of teacher and
it's actually really inspiring I was
genuinely surprised at how inspiring
this was when I rewatched this movie
tonight because this movie sets up so
much tension between Hogwarts between
the Ministry of Magic between Umbridge
and Harry and all of these characters
and of course Voldemort right in the
middle who's manipulating everybody and
so you are so behind these characters
and for me order of the Phoenix is the
first film in which this world truly
feels as if it is an operating world
with governments and agencies and you
can
really feel all of that coming into play
here the friendship and the love between
these characters is very strongly felt
because that's important that's super
important for the message of this movie
to pay off and we also get some really
hilarious scenes like this one so I love
that the Harry Potter movies get darker
and darker and more intense and more
dramatic but I love even more that these
characters are still so well maintained
and that that love and that friendship
and that fun is still there and just
like with Goblet of Fire we explore
puberty a little bit more when harry
gets his first kiss in this film
underneath mistletoe no less we also
finally learned a little bit more about
Snape's past and it was actually kind of
haunting we got inside Snape's memory
when he's trying to train harry to try
to teach him to discipline his mind and
harry uses that spell right back on
Snape and learns that his father used to
kind of be Snape's Draco I understand
why Snape is Snape now so the kids
eventually concoct a plot using a giant
that they have learned his Hagrid's
half-brother to get Umbridge out of this
school and eventually the Centaurs
actually come and take her away because
the Ministry of Magic has been
restricting their grounds as well so the
kids can now use everything they've been
training for to try to actually go out
there and fight against Voldemort and
his forces and they travel to London and
a gigantic epic showdown takes place and
this is our first real look at magic war
and holy shit
it was awesome David Yates did such a
great job directing these sequences
there is something absolutely as I said
very dreamlike and euphoric about his
direction
Voldemort appears Dumbledore serious
everyone is out there using magic the
kids and it is really really exciting
and Harry experiences more loss when
Bellatrix appears and kills Sirius and
my god this scene was painful I actually
read that they muted Harry's scream
because it was just so absolutely
agonizing they felt it was too intense
it works in the movie muted but I'm
actually curious to hear how it sounded
Harry is so consumed with rage that he
goes
Derr Bellatrix but he withstands the
temptation that Voldemort is piling on
him to kill her again showing us why
this kid is such a great role model and
I haven't really talked about it but the
character of Luna Lovegood oh my god she
is so cool
I love this character she's just so
funny and weird and different and that's
another thing that JK Rowling has really
tapped into with these books and the
movies characters that really just feel
like you know them like you've seen
people like that there's somebody you
can relate to in every scene Harry
Potter and the order of the Phoenix
managed to be darkly intense supremely
exciting and powerfully heartfelt all at
once and that is really hard to do I
think this is one of the more underrated
films in the franchise and I'm going to
give Harry Potter and the order of the
Phoenix and a guys thank you so much as
always for watching my continuing series
of Harry Potter reviews I'm having such
a great time doing this stay tuned for
Harry Potter and the half-blood Prince
you guys are the best thank you so much
once again and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
you